hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a review of
Christopher Nolan's new movie Dunkirk
and even though Nolan is better known
for directing the Dark Knight trilogy
and Inception here he proved himself
just as capable with a new genre war
film and really I think Dunkirk is up
there with the most authentic war movies
of all time Saving Private Ryan Black
Hawk Down but really it's not just the
gritty realism that makes Dunkirk an
honest war film it's actually in my
opinion how Nolan innovates in the way
that he tells this story but before I
get to that the whole reason we get to
make this video it's because World of
Tanks is sponsoring it it's an amazing
game and tanks actually played a pivotal
role in the events leading up to the
Battle of Dunkirk so stick around at the
end of the video for a preview and a
special offer of free stuff also before
I move on some of the stuff I get into
in this review might be considered
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
I'm actually going to avoid major plot
twists but even so you'll probably
appreciate this more if you go watch
Dunkirk first
come on let's support a war movie that
isn't about American for a change
okay so Nolan depicts the famous world
war 2 battle in which four hundred
thousand stranded Allied troops
miraculously escaped the advancing
Germans by crossing the English Channel
on hundreds of ships including many
civilian vessels and like many
historical battles there were a lot of
angles to the story actually went into
this fascinating history in another
video that we just put up but here no
one structures this whole movie with
three different concurrent timelines
which are all laid out in the opening
minutes one the mole showing these
soldiers trying to get off the beach
which takes place over the course of one
week to the sea showing British
civilians piloting a yacht to rescue
those soldiers which takes place over
the course of one day and three the air
showing two British Spitfire pilots as
they get in dogfights with German pilots
over the channel no that takes place
over the course of one hour so just to
clarify this this scenes with Tommy
Gibson and the commander's last a whole
week the scenes with mr. Dawson Peter
and George take place on the final day
of that week and the scenes with Ferrier
and Collins take place on the final hour
of that
all day with all three of these
timelines converging in one climactic
scene so like he did with inception and
interstellar in memento Christopher
Nolan is telling this story with a
nonlinear timeline and yes this decision
did bug some critics who called it a
gimmick but it's not a gimmick it's
actually in my opinion one of the
reasons this movie is a triumph so let's
talk about how this storytelling
decision affects each aspect of the film
first let's look at the characters so a
big reason why Nolan does this I think
is to share the focus among several
characters in different parts of the
battle and yeah in real wars people in
different parts of a battle perceive the
passage of time differently like those
soldiers on the beach probably felt like
time was slowly ticking away over those
several days with the enemy gradually
closing in and no rescue in sight
meanwhile the civilians on both crossing
the channel probably measured time in
daylight as the Sun moves across the sky
to mark the time of the day and the
pilots in the air with limited fuel
measured time in minutes of an hour
which we see Ferrier do throughout the
movie and this way we get to see all of
these characters as no one character
takes the spotlight as the hero like in
true battles victory and survival is a
group effort so in Dunkirk several
characters are heroic in different ways
Tommy
Gibson commander Bolton the crew of the
moonstone Ferrier Collins while others
are less than heroic interestingly two
of the biggest stars of this movie Harry
Styles as the British soldier Alex and
Killian Murphy as the unnamed shivering
soldier bill Nolan makes it very clear
that these characters aren't villains
and Bank despite the Shivering soldier
being a deserter who's called a coward
another character defends him saying
he's just shell-shocked and he's not
himself and he may never be again really
if you think about it the villain of
this movie is another product of Nolan's
timeline and Dunkirk the villain isn't
the German it's time like we never
really see the Germans in this movie
they're depicted as out-of-focus figures
in the background or tiny dots in the
sky or the sounds of gunfire in the
distance inevitable certain deaths that
these soldiers have no chance to defeat
outright in this battle instead all of
these characters are racing time holding
off the Germans
just long enough so that they can escape
and live to fight another day and
framing this conflict as a race against
time makes some soldiers more relatable
in a way like I've never fought in the
war against German soldiers but I have
prayed as my car was Ani
hoping to last the gas station yeah our
generation really has it easy another
benefit of Noland splitting up the
timelines this way is he gets to show us
how it felt to be in different physical
settings of Dunkirk World War two was
fought on three fronts land sea and sky
and Noland depicts each with different
types of shots showing the varying
passing of time with different pacing as
he transitions among these shots so for
example on land Noland uses mostly lock
shot stationary on a tripod or rig or
panning smoothly on a dolly these shots
picked by for several seconds without
cutting as the soldiers gradually look
up and read at an incoming German bomber
and the camera lingers on specific
details like the grains of sand on its
soldiers knuckles as he does some covers
Nolan stretches out these shots to evoke
time dragging by on the beach meanwhile
Nolan switches to handheld for the shots
on the boat letting the camera rock and
Bob with the wave and it whisks and cuts
abruptly as they float closer in close
to the danger time feels like it's
moving by more and more quickly then
finally Nolan jumps around like crazy in
the air going from tight close-ups a
party to his point of view as the target
the enemy two shots with a camera on the
side of the plane two close-ups of his
tiny rear view mirror and the occasional
bird's-eye view of the sea below this
matches the frantic mind of a pilot mid
dog sight everything in the cockpit is
up-close and cramped our view like his
view is limited with an enemy planes
suddenly appearing overhead or behind
him this battle is so amazing to watch
and the only way Nolan can work it in
the film is by failing each timeline so
that the movie builds up to it at a
precise moment and let's actually move
on to the story so telling the story of
Dunkirk through these three different
timelines allows Nolan to balance the
scale of this movie so like in other
great war movies those directors chose
to zoom in and focus those stories on
one soldier or one group of soldiers
with their specific missions reflecting
the war as a whole like you can imagine
how some
might have watched Saving Private Ryan
and thought oh of course Tom Hanks won
world war two the other option is to
zoom out and show lots of stories the
battlefield but also the enemy the
politics the homefront thinks the
longest day or Pearl Harbor but also
movies like Independence Day or the Lord
of the Rings those stories are epic and
they show several perspectives but it's
a little hard to maintain realism like
aliens and wizards guys come on
but in Dunkirk by using shifting but
concurrent timelines Nolan is able to
have both he can tell the story of
soldiers waiting long hopeless days for
deliverance while also telling a story
of high-speed pilot zipping through the
air
this gives Dunkirk the intimacy of a
movie like Saving Private Ryan but also
the epic payoff of a movie like an
offended stay it also enables Nolan to
structure these storylines in a way that
builds suspense so without spoiling
specific details some characters are
seen in grave danger in some timelines
and we don't find out what their fates
are until other timelines swoop in and
pick up these stories this is actually
where some of the criticisms come in so
let's talk about those now the reason
some critics see this as a gimmick is
that one could argue Nolan is simply
telling the story out of order to create
these artificial cliffhangers and that
that isn't real tension for example some
people complain that his movie Inception
relied too much on editing to create
this illusion of danger in its final
sequence there's a lot of frantic
cutting back and forth between
characters as we worried about their
survival rather than a more classic way
to build suspense by showing a character
in a moral dilemma making a tough
decision and sure I guess I kind of hear
that but that's not what Nolan is doing
here the whole idea of not knowing right
away whether someone lives or dies is a
very real aspect of soldiers in world
war ii pilots often wouldn't know
whether their fellow pilots were dead in
the cockpit or just lost radio contact
so really nolan only leaves us in the
dark when they would have made sense for
these soldiers to be left in the dark
another criticism that i suppose you
could make about Christopher Nolan is
that his ambition to tell stories with
nonlinear timelines sometimes leaves his
stories with plot holes you can find
plenty of snarky videos online about the
plot holes of Inception or interstellar
and sure and Dunkirk it's a little
convenient how often Tom Hardy swoops in
to save the day but I would argue again
no one isn't meddling with timelines in
his movies because he's Chris memento
Nolan and he loves to make our heads
hurt each time he does it it comes from
a logical place in the world of
characters like in Inception time moves
more slowly in dreams because that's how
we perceive time to move in dreams
Nolan derived that from a real human
experience then an interstellar time
moves more quickly on a planet because
it's near a black hole where the gravity
is affecting the people's perception of
time that's a real concept from
astrophysics in memento half the movie
unfolds in Reverse
because the lead character has a
cognitive disorder that causes them to
process memories in a unique way and in
the Dark Knight Rises Bruce Wayne can
heal a broken back climb out of prison
travel across the earth on foot and
access a closed-off city under siege all
in a few days because he's Batman shut
up
my point is Nolan doesn't force timeline
stuff on us for no reason this isn't
like the movie crash which opens on a
crime scene and then randomly jumps back
in time where we later find out that's
the body and the crime scene is
someone's Don Cheadle knows guys somehow
that movie won Best Picture no one is a
filmmaker who is clearly drawn to
stories where characters have a unique
relationship to time and that is a deep
existential question and I'm glad we
have a bold innovative director like
Chris Nolan trying to tackle it in
various genres so did it work now in
case you just started watching this
video now yeah
Dunkirk totally works for me and
whatever your thoughts are about this
timeline structure you can't deny that
it results in a nolan being way more
economical with its pacing this movie is
only an hour and 47 minutes long most of
Nolan's movies had been well over 2
hours only his first film following was
shorter and in that hour 47 Dunkirk
rarely slows down breaking up the air
battle among the timelines makes the
movie feel like one exciting action
sequence kind of like Mad Max fury road
really I'm always game for nolan
exploring new ways and new orders to
tell a story and it really doesn't
matter what genre we made one of the
best superhero movies ever with the Dark
Knight one of the best heist movies ever
was inception one of the best sci-fi
movies with
interstellar and now one of the best war
films ever with Dunkirk and he pulled it
off by creating a structure that allowed
him to explore several different
characters perceptions of the chronology
of one famous event thus depicting the
Battle of Dunkirk with the honesty it
deserves and needs right now and yeah
this is Batman remember Batman anyway
that's my take but let me know if you
feel differently do you think Dunkirk
needed this alternate timeline structure
would you have preferred if it just
stayed with one of those stories or
shown each one after the other okay
again I'm so glad we even got to make
this video and the reason we could it's
because World of Tanks sponsored it
World of Tanks is an awesome game where
you can command history's most powerful
tanks and experience tactical combat
like never before it's set in the mid
20th century and you have access to an
impressive roster of over 450 authentic
tanks from powerful steel brawlers to
lightning-fast Scouts if you were me
seeing a great movie like Dunkirk might
have just gotten you back into we're
history as a subject and World of Tanks
is great about making me feel part of
that action and letting you join this
armored warfare sensation with 150
million people worldwide click on the
link below in the description and the
first 300 viewers to use our unique code
of tanks rule 2017 will get seven days
of premium time along with 350 gold and
a free premium tank so guys you've got
to get on this this game is awesome
definitely worth trying out okay
remember to check out my other Dunkirk
video where I go into the really
interesting true backstory of Dunkirk
and let me know your thoughts in the
comments below you can also tweet me
directly at a variety rockstars and if
you feel generous contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our current
donors especially Wilhelmina ebbesson
you are amazing thank you for watching
and hey thank you to our editor for not
editing this blue screen to keep me in
front of some embarrassing background oh
I shouldn't put that down your head